c'est à la sortie de ce virage sur l'a38
hauteur de pont de pany que le drame
s'est produit hier soir vers 22h40 un
véhicule circulant à contresens percuté
une autre voiture bilan un mort et un
blessé grave dans le véhicule qui
roulait à contresens dans l'autre
voiture françois patriat est blessé nous
avons pu le joindre à l'hôpital de dijon
où il a été transporté par les pompiers
l'ancien président du conseil régional
se veut rassurant même s'il parle de
miracle tout son autoroute gens venus du
mac il ya rien 4 430 et supercap ne
difficile et la vue devant au dernier
moment lui il applique il a pu éviter la
voiture qui arrivait en face comme il
fait des tournées moi j'ai eu la voiture
en plus en faisant moins tout un choc
frontal rejeté à son 31 cents à 239 suis
pas comment je suis en rien à la tête
rien au bras rien aujourd'hui et pas de
lésions internes graves sur les réseaux
sociaux les messages de soutien sont
nombreux les politiques de tous bords
lui souhaite un prompt rétablissement et
avant de raccrocher françois patriat
nous glisse qu emmanuel macron l'avait
aussi appelé emmanuel macron à qui la
portait récemment son soutien politique